But roughly speaking ever since smog,
it's natural for every two pounds we pay
and we get one pound back in.
The one pound we get back is under
conditions.
So I think we're going to be stronger
because our economy is strong.
If the vote leave,
I think going to be safer because we've
got greater control of our borders.
Who voted leave and I think we're going
to be better off and we're going to be
better off because the European Union
was created in a time when big trading
blox existed.
They don't exist anymore.
What we've got now is global trading of
goods,
global trading of services,
and we also have global movement of
people.
None of these things the ear is capable
of dealing with.
It has outgrown its time.
I wish the euro countries well,
they need deeper integration.
They need it because I don't want how
generations of young people to be on a
heap of unemployment.
I wish them well.
I think we're better off to vote.
Leave.
If we are strong and they're strong than
the continent of Europe is strong.
If we collectively week that will serve
no one.
So take control,
vote leave.
[inaudible].